jus d'orange n'importe quoi les
médicaments tout est beau même s'il a
vendu sa résidence jean pierre audet
maintient le lien avec monique gagnon
qui a été sa locataire pendant 13 ans
j'avais affaire à l'hôpital pour des
tests de prendre un taxi si lui ceux qui
venaient sur meu notre conduite quatorze
des seize locataires ont quitté depuis
la vente de cette résidence pour
personnes âgées en juillet pourtant le
coût des loyers a baissé mais plusieurs
services ont disparu
on va toujours s'occuper d'elle pareil
mais aussi en avant que le nouveau
propriétaire ne veut pas du statut de
résidence pour personnes âgées un cas
parmi des dizaines d'autres depuis deux
ans au québec le nombre de rpa est passé
de 1259 à 1181 soixante dix huit
résidents sont donc fermés ou changer de
statut surtout de petites résidences
comme celle ci après 13 ans jean pierre
audet mais la clé dans la porte moi
j'aurais continué devrait continuer mais
écouter ils sont après nous autres on a
mal au pays que n'importe quoi la
reddition de comptes serait trop lourde
la mise à niveau du bâtiment très cher
et la pénurie de personnel insoluble en
sus d'être somme lng jdd préposé avec
découvre même si c'est une petite
résidence il nous prenait pour des
hôpitaux où il suit on voulait qu'on ait
la même chose que des grosses résidence
les coûts d'exploitation des résidences
plombent leur rentabilité surtout que la
hausse des loyers est limité à environ
2% cette année l'alimentation en moyenne
28 à 32% l'énergie électricité gaz
eau vite pour ça
comment est-ce qu'on peut arriver quand
on ne dit plus augmenté de 1.8 ou 2%
mais vos coûts augmentent en moyenne au
dessus de 20 pour ça et la pandémie a
fait baisser la demande le taux
d'inoccupation a bondi en un an de 6,9 à
12,8 pour cent le modèle économique des
rpa est devenu moins intéressant ça
explique en partie pourquoi même de
grosses résidence comme mont carmel à
montréal sont convertis en logements
mais plusieurs souhaitent que québec
intervienne et bloquent ces conversions
faudrait qu'il ya une instance
gouvernementale qui a plus la vente par
plusieurs personnes avec dans le cas de
nuisances personnes âgées qui a déjà une
vocation dédié avant de changer la
vocation de cet édifice là faut dire
qu'il ya une approbation social que la
progression sociale elle se fait par des
instances gouvernementales
d'autres proposent de nos simplement
plus subventionner les résidences pour
personnes âgées québec verse environ 500
millions en crédits d'impôt aux
résidents chaque année de l'argent qui
pourrait aller ailleurs d'investir
massivement dans les services à domicile
public et met une bonne manière de le
faire à coup presque nul ce serait
justement de prendre ces crédits des
pôles qui sont embauchés par les
résidences privées pour aînés et de
puteaux les investir dans les services à
domicile pour que les gens puissent
choisir de rester à la maison un virage
qui semble urgent de nombreux
entrepreneurs comme jean pierre audet
disent que même avec les crédits d'impôt
la rentabilité est de plus en plus
difficile et shito ryu ken chun ça peut
être un beau challenge chambre je pense
pas que quelqu'un puisse bien vive il
faut pas oublier mal gagnon de faire un
petit peu d'exercice d'un passage la
passion de monsieur audet était encore
là on est très loin d'une froide
fermeture décidée par une multinationale
ce que ça fait quelque chose
mais
un deuil
ici david gendt il est arrêté au canada
montréal